David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 27 of the collection of Illinois Institute of Technology, taken in Paris on August the 5th, on 9 Rue Guy Patin, a home for adult displaced people, especially Jews. The interviewee is, eh, Miss Rita Benmayor, eh, age twenty, from Jewish Greek, from Saloniki? From Saloniki. Eh, she carries on her left arm a tattoo number, 38758, underneath a little triangle, indicating her Jewish descent.
David Boder: [In German] Nun, sagen sie mir, Frau, eh, Fräulein, eh, Benmayor, eh, wo sind sie geboren, wer ist ihre Familie, und wieviel waren Sie in der Famile und womit haben sich Ihre Eltern beschäftigt?
Rita Benmayor: Ich bin geboren in Griechenland, und ’43, on ’43, die Deutsch gekommen Griechenland, die hab ganz Familie genommen.
David Boder: Ja—wieviel Menschen waren in ihrer Familie?
Rita Benmayor: Meine Familie war fünf Leute.
David Boder: Fünf Leute, wer waren das, sagen Sie?
Rita Benmayor: Meine Vater, Mutter und zwei Brüder und ich.
David Boder: Ja, now—wo sind jetzt Ihre Vater und Ihre Mutter?
Rita Benmayor: Meine Vater, meine Mutter war deportier-, und ganze Familie war im Krematorium, war im Krematorium, alle gesterben.
David Boder: Eh, Ihre zwei Brüder auch?
Rita Benmayor: Meine zwei Brüder auch.
David Boder: Nun?
Rita Benmayor: Ich hab geblieben ganz alleine von die Familie.
David Boder: Ja, also—sagen Sie mal, wenn die Deutschen gekommen sind in ’42, wie alt war Ihr Vater?
Rita Benmayor: Meine Vater war 40 Jahre.
David Boder: Und ihre Mutter?
Rita Benmayor: Meine Mutter war 38 Jahre.
David Boder: Und die zwei Brüder?
Rita Benmayor: Zwei Brüder, eine 25 und eine 18 Jahre.
David Boder: Waren Sie—und wie, wie alt waren Sie?
Rita Benmayor: Ich war 16 Jahre.
David Boder: Sie waren 16—nun, und waren Ihre Brüder verheiratet?
Rita Benmayor: Der eine war ‘erheirat und der andere war nicht verheiratet.
David Boder: . . . war nicht verheiratet—und wo ist, eh, die Frau von dem verheiraten Bruder?
Rita Benmayor: Die Frau von dem verheirat Bruder war auch im Krematorium, die hat klein Kinder gehabt und war in Krematorium.
David Boder: Sie hat -ach, sie hat ein kleines Kind gehabt?
Rita Benmayor: Ja, sie hat viel klein Kind.
David Boder: Wieviel?
Rita Benmayor: Vier.
David Boder: Sie hatte vier kleine Kinder?
Rita Benmayor: Sie war vier...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Vier.
David Boder: Nun, erzählen Sie mir, eh, die Ihre ganze Geschichte, wo hat ihr Bruder, ihr verheirateter Bruder mit seiner Frau gelebt, hat er mit Ihnen gelebt oder hat er für sich selbst gelebt?
Rita Benmayor: Er hat ihre gelebt.
David Boder: Was, er hat für sich selbst gelebt—erzählen Sie—hat für sich selbst gelebt?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Also erzählen Sie, sie haben in Saloniki gelebt?
Rita Benmayor: Jawohl.
David Boder: Ja, sprechen Sie lauter, und sprechen Sie bitte in diese Weg [?]. Nun gut, also dann: die Deutschen sind gekommen nach Saloniki, und was haben die dort befohlen und was haben die dort gemacht?
Rita Benmayor: Wann die Deutsch gekommen Saloniki, das war gut, [?] sie...
David Boder: Aha...
Rita Benmayor: . . . und dann dreiund—zweiundvierzig...
David Boder: Aha, ja...
Rita Benmayor: . . . und dann in ’43 die Gestapo gekommen und der haben alle Jude genommen.
David Boder: Die haben alle Juden genommen—wo haben sie sie genommen?
Rita Benmayor: Es waren 2 Uhr bei Nacht, das war gekommen zuhause und hat ganze Familie genommen.
David Boder: Und wo hat man Sie hingebracht?
Rita Benmayor: No, gebracht in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Nun ja, also gleich vom Hause, wo hat man sie genommen zur, eh, Station?
Rita Benmayor: . . . zum Station von Saloniki.
David Boder: Also, sagen sie, man ist gekommen um 2 Uhr in der Nacht—und wo hat man sie genommen, direkt vom Hause...
Rita Benmayor: . . . von zuhause...
David Boder: . . . von zuhause...
Rita Benmayor: . . . von zuhause hat genommen ganze Familie und—
David Boder: . . . und man hat...
Rita Benmayor: . . . und war in Station im Waggon...und war 72 Leute im Waggon...
David Boder: Ja, was war das, ein Passagier-Waggon, oder ein eh...ein eh...Wa...ein eh—Waren-Waggon...
Rita Benmayor: Ja, eh, Waggon...
David Boder: . . . ein Waren-Waggon—waren dort Bänke zu sitzen im Waggon?
Rita Benmayor: Nein, runter gesitzen...
David Boder: Man ist gesessen auf der Diele...
Rita Benmayor: . . . gesitzen, ja...
David Boder: War da, eh, eine Toilette- war da ein Kabinett?
Rita Benmayor: Nein, das war eine—Kübel...
David Boder: Da war ein Kübel dort...
Rita Benmayor: . . . ein Kübel...
David Boder: Und waren Männer und Frauen zusammen im Waggon?
Rita Benmayor: Ja. Waren 72 Leute, Männer und Frauen, klein Kinder, alle zusammen.
David Boder: . . . und kleine—Ja. Nun, und was hat man gesagt, wohin nimmt man sie?
Rita Benmayor: Er hat gesagt, es kommen alle in Polen, und alle Jude zusammen.
David Boder: Alle Juden zusammen...
Rita Benmayor: Aber hat nicht gewusst, was wird gemacht...
David Boder: Sie haben nicht gewusst.
Rita Benmayor: Wir haben nicht gewusst.
David Boder: Ja—also...und so sind Sie gefahren, wie lange sind Sie gefahren?
Rita Benmayor: . . . eh...
David Boder: . . . von Saloniki im Zug, wie lange sind Sie gefahren?
Rita Benmayor: Acht Tage...
David Boder: Sie sind acht Tage...
Rita Benmayor: . . . im acht Tage, wir habt in Auschwitz gekommen, warn in Auschwitz.
David Boder: . . . in Auschwitz gekommen—was hat dort in Auschwitz passiert?
Rita Benmayor: . . . warn wir in Auschwitz, wir habt die Deutsch gekommen, sar—die Männer...
David Boder: . . . apartiert...
Rita Benmayor: . . . apartier, und die Frauen apartier...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Die Männer hat genommen eine Automobil, das bald in Krematorium. Der hat die alte Leute...
David Boder: Ach, das warn die alte Leute...
Rita Benmayor: . . . die alte Leute war bald in Krematorium...und die junge Leute war in Lager.
David Boder: Ja—und was hat man mit Ihnen getan?
Rita Benmayor: Ich war jung, ich war 16 Jahre, und hat mich genommen und alle zusammen...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Arbeiten in Lager, in eine Lager.
David Boder: Ja. Und eh...
Rita Benmayor: . . . meine...
David Boder: Sie sind gekommen nach Auschwitz zusammen mit Ihre Vater und Ihre Mutter?
Rita Benmayor: Ja, meine...
David Boder: Und Ihr Va...Ja?
Rita Benmayor: Meine Mutter gesehen in Auto, gehn in Auto—warum, die warn alte—und meine Vater auch in Auto, bald in Krematorium geschaff...
David Boder: Gut, Sie Sie sagen, Ihr Vater war 40 Jahre, das ist doch nicht alt.
Rita Benmayor: Ja. Aber hat so gemacht...
David Boder: Ja. Das haben die gemacht—und Ihre Brüder, eh, und Ihre zwei Brüder?
Rita Benmayor: Die eine Bruder, ich haben nicht gewusst alles...und die andere, die war auch in andere Lager.
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Und die geht in libere...
David Boder: Oh, und der ist free, frei gekommen?
Rita Benmayor: Frei gekommen.
David Boder: Und wo ist er jetzt?
Rita Benmayor: Jetzt ist in Palästina.
David Boder: In Palästina?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Wie ist er dort rüber gekommen?
Rita Benmayor: . . .
David Boder: Ohne Permit. Sprechen Sie darein...
Rita Benmayor: Ohne Permit...
David Boder: Ist einfach rüber gegangen und ist reingekommen?
Rita Benmayor: Wann ist freit, er war in Griechenland, er hat gesucht die Familie. Er hat gewusst die ganze Familie...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: . . . niemei—und es war in Palästina.
David Boder: Ja, und er ist- hat er Ihnen von Palästina geschrieben?
Rita Benmayor: Nein, er hat zurückge —er, äh, ja.
David Boder: Hat er Ihnen geschrieben?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Sie wissen, dass er dort ist?
David Boder: Ja, und, eh...nun, und so sind Sie im Lager geblieben, was hat man mit Ihnen im Lager getan?
Rita Benmayor: Ich?
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Wann ich war in Lager, hat die Deutsche genommen, hat mich ganze Haare ge-, geschn...
David Boder: Ihr ganzen Haare hat man abgeschnitten.
Rita Benmayor: Geschnitte.
David Boder: [In English] She now has a wonderful head of hair, that she says that her hair will—was cut off entirely.
David Boder: [In German] Nun. Man hat Ihre Haare abgeschnitten, dann?
Rita Benmayor: Die Haare geschnitte, hat mich ganze Kleid genommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Hat mich gegeben eine Männerkleid.
David Boder: Ja, Männerkleidung?
Rita Benmayor: Eine Männeranzug, ja.
David Boder: Ja, ein Männeranzug—auch Hosen?
Rita Benmayor: Männeranzug, Hose und Jacke.
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Und dann ich war Arbeit bei die Straße.
David Boder: Arbeiten auf der Straße?
Rita Benmayor: Auf der Straße.
David Boder: Und wann hat man Sie tattooiert—wann hat man die Tatoo gemacht?
Rita Benmayor: Die erste Tag wann war in Lager gekommen...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: . . . das war zwei Häftlinge, der hat ganze...
David Boder: Ja, das hat...
Rita Benmayor: . . . die Nummer gemacht.
David Boder: . . . die Nummer gemacht.
Rita Benmayor: . . . war zwei Männer...
David Boder: . . . und dann, wenn man Ihnen die Nummer gemacht hat, dann haben Sie schon gewusst, dass Sie leben bleiben werden, dass Sie...
Rita Benmayor: Nein.
David Boder: Warum nicht?
Rita Benmayor: Warum, wir habt die Nummer ausgenommen, aber wir war mager, ganze Monat, wie—alle Monate hat Selektion gehabt.
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: . . . wer ist mager, wer schlecht ausgab, ganz in Krematorium, der hat...
David Boder: . . . das war in Auschwitz?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Ja, und, eh, wie so haben Sie sich gesund erhalten?
Rita Benmayor: Nun ich hab alle Schmutz gegessen, wir habt geklaut eine mit andere die Brot, wir habt das gemacht.
David Boder: Was heißt, wir haben Schmutz ge-, Schmutz gegessen?
Rita Benmayor: Die Schmutz von die Kartoffel...
David Boder: Die Schmutz von die Kartoffel haben Sie gegessen?
Rita Benmayor: . . . die Kartoffel—ich hat gegessen.
David Boder: . . . und das hat Sie erhalten ein bisschen stärker?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Und, eh, sie sagen, weiter Sie haben voneinander das Brot weg genommen?
Rita Benmayor: Ja, eh...
David Boder: Sprechen Sie weiter...Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, und was haben Sie gearbeitet? In Auschwitz?
Rita Benmayor: Die erste Monat, drei Monat, ich habe bei die Straße gearbeit, Schneise, äh, Steine ge...
David Boder: Sie haben Steine gearbeit...
Rita Benmayor: Steine ge...
David Boder: Ja—nun?
Rita Benmayor: Und dann ich war die Schuhkommando, ich habe Schuhe repariert, ich war die Schuhkommando...
David Boder: Eh, Sie waren im Schuhkommando?
Rita Benmayor: Schuhkommando...
David Boder: Haben Sie gelernt, Schuhe zu reparieren?
Rita Benmayor: . . . Schuhe zu reparieren.
David Boder: Eh, eh, von wem waren die Schuhe?
Rita Benmayor: Von die SS.
David Boder: Oh, die waren SS-Schuhe?
Rita Benmayor: . . . SS-Schuhe.
David Boder: Eh—haben Sie—womit haben Sie gearbeitet, mit, eh, mit Hammer, oder mit der Maschine?
Rita Benmayor: Mit Arme.
David Boder: Was?
David Boder: Mit Ihre Hände haben Sie gearbeitet?
Rita Benmayor: Mit Ihre Hände.
David Boder: Und, eh, haben Sie richtig gelernt zu reparieren Schuhe?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Können Sie das jetzt noch?
David Boder: Können Sie ein Schuhmacher sein?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Ja, nun, und...
Rita Benmayor: Ich war eine Jahre im Schuhkommando.
David Boder: Sie waren ein ganzes Jahr im Schuhkommando.
Rita Benmayor: Ein ganzes Jahr im Schuhkommando.
David Boder: Ein ganzes Jahr im Schukommando.
Rita Benmayor: Jawohl.
David Boder: Und dann, was hat passiert?
Rita Benmayor: Und dann, wann wir—wann die Russe gekommen Auschwitz, wir habt transportiert nach andere Lager...
David Boder: Aha, wenn die Russen nach Auschwitz gekommen sind...
Rita Benmayor: . . . wir habt transportiert...
David Boder: Hat man Sie transportier nach andere...
Rita Benmayor: . . . in andere Lager, wir war in Ravensbrück.
David Boder: Ravensbrück, wo ist das?
Rita Benmayor: In Deutschland.
David Boder: Das ist in Deutschland, nun erzählen Sie, wieviel Tage sind Sie gefahren von Auschwitz nach Ravensbrück?
Rita Benmayor: Na, fünf Tage wir habt gelaufen, in bei Fuß...
David Boder: Sie sind zu Fuß gegangen fünf Tage?
Rita Benmayor: Fünf Tage...
David Boder: Er, eh, wer, wieviel Menschen sind zu Fuß gegangen?
Rita Benmayor: Drei Men-, dreihundert Menschen.
David Boder: Dreihundert Menschen, Männer und Frauen?
Rita Benmayor: Nein, nur Frauen.
David Boder: Nur Frauen, und wer hat sie aufgepasst?
Rita Benmayor: Die, eh, die Posten von die SS.
David Boder: Die SS, waren die gut zu Ihnen?
Rita Benmayor: Nein, wer hat kann nicht viel laufen, der schnell er...
David Boder: Was, erschossen?
Rita Benmayor: . . . ereschossen.
David Boder: Oh, haben Sie das selbst gesehen?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Ja, was tuten die...
Rita Benmayor: Viel.
David Boder: Was haben sie getan, mit einem Revolver sie erschossen?
Rita Benmayor: Ne, schoa sie...die hat gescho...[?]
David Boder: Ach die, die Flinte?
Rita Benmayor: Die Flinte, ja.
David Boder: Haben sie genommen und sie gleich erschossen.
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: . . . und...
Rita Benmayor: . . . wer kann gut laufen, er hat gelaufen, wer kann nicht laufen, der hat nicht gegessen, der hat...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: . . . nur ein Brot für vier Tage...
Rita Benmayor: . . . der hat gegessen alle zwei Tage, gegessen die Brot...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: . . . er hat, kann nicht laufen, er hat schnell erschossen.
David Boder: Nun, und so sind Sie from Auschwitz wohin gekommen?
Rita Benmayor: Nach Ravensbrück.
David Boder: Sie sind nach Ravensbrück gekommen, und was hat man dort gemacht?
Rita Benmayor: Wir habt dort, eh, wieder die Straße lang gearbeitet.
David Boder: Was haben sie gearbeitet Straße?
Rita Benmayor: Steine tragen.
David Boder: Steine tragen, und was hat man, eine Straße gebaut?
Rita Benmayor: St-, eh, ja.
David Boder: Ja, nun und denn?
Rita Benmayor: Wir hat dort vier Monat gearbeit, und dann wir hab, eh...bei Stucko[?] war so...
David Boder: Was?
Rita Benmayor: . . . im Block gearbeit.
David Boder: Im Block gearbeitet, wieviel Leute waren Sie im Block?
Rita Benmayor: Im Block wart 150 Leute.
David Boder: 150 Leute, wie haben Sie im Block geschlafen?
Rita Benmayor: [?]...in die...
David Boder: Was?
Rita Benmayor: In die Bett.
David Boder: Waren Betten, oder...?
Rita Benmayor: Waren fünf Leute in eine Bett geschlafen.
David Boder: Fünf Leute in einem Bett?
Rita Benmayor: Fünf Leute in eine kleine Bett.
David Boder: Eh, also haben Sie, eh, haben Sie, war es rein, war es sauber?
Rita Benmayor: Sauber, ja?
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Ja, das war sauber.
David Boder: Sie haben sich waschen können, und so—haben Sie Läuse gehabt, Flöhe, Läuse?
Rita Benmayor: Läuse, viele.
David Boder: Oh, sie hatten viele Läuse?
Rita Benmayor: Wir hat viel Läuse.
David Boder: Und was haben sie getan, um sich von den Läuse freizumachen?
Rita Benmayor: [?] wir habt so in...
David Boder: Was, sich gekratzt?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: [In English] Eh...? She said they scratched themselves.
David Boder: [In German] Nun, also, eh, und dann, wie lange waren Sie dort in diesem Lager, wie heißt das zweite Lager?
Rita Benmayor: Ist Ravensbrück.
David Boder: Das heißt Ravesblick [does not know the camp]...und, eh, wie lange waren Sie in Ravensbrück?
Rita Benmayor: Vier Monate.
David Boder: Vier Monate, und was hat denn passiert?
Rita Benmayor: Hat immer dort...
David Boder: Ja, aber nach die vier Monate, was hat dort passiert?
Rita Benmayor: Und dann wir hat wieder transportiert, warum die Russ gekomm nach Ravensbrück, wieder transportiert nach andere Lager, Retzow...
David Boder: Nach, hat man Sie nach Retzow transpor...
Rita Benmayor: Retzow.
David Boder: Ja, und was hat man...
Rita Benmayor: Wir hat wieder dort Steine trage, bei die Straße, Star gearbeit...
David Boder: Was, haben Sie immer Straßen gebaut?
Rita Benmayor: Ja, immer dort.
David Boder: Immer Straßen gebaut, nun, und so haben Sie in Retzow gearbeitet, und wie lange waren Sie in Retzow?
Rita Benmayor: Drei Monate.
David Boder: Drei Monate—wie hat man sich dort benommen mit Ihnen, wie hat man Sie, eh, behandelt? Waren sie gut zu Ihnen oder lieb?
Rita Benmayor: In Raven..., in Retzow, das war nicht gut, hat nicht gehabt sich zu essen, wir hat einmal Suppe gehabt und ein kleine Stück Brot zu essen.
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Hat viele Leute sind gesterbe von Hunger.
David Boder: Sind Leute—nun sagen Sie mal, sind gestorben von Hunger, wie stellt man das, von Hunger, was, wie ist das regiert[?] passierte?
Rita Benmayor: Früh wir hat Kaffee getrinkt...
David Boder: Nun?
Rita Benmayor: Um Mittag eine halbe Liter Suppe...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Und abend eine kleine Stück Brot zu esse.
David Boder: Nun, und sagen sie, Leute sind von Hunger gestorben, was hat ihnen passiert? Sind sie krank geworden, sind sie mager geworden, was...?
Rita Benmayor: Na, da mage...
David Boder: Mager...
Rita Benmayor: . . . da kann nicht laufen, die SS hat, eh...
David Boder: Eh, mit der Peitsche...?
Rita Benmayor: Mit der Peitsche, und lange...
David Boder: [In English] She makes a gesture.
David Boder: [In German] Haben sie mit der Peitsche geschlagen, nun, und?
Rita Benmayor: Und sterben.
David Boder: Und sie sind gestorben. Oh, sagen Sie, was hat man genannt ein Muselmann, wissen Sie, was das ist?
Rita Benmayor: Muselmann, ja.
David Boder: Ja, was ist das?
Rita Benmayor: Der—nicht gegessen, es war Muselmann, und die SS, die hat genommen die Muselmann, gleich nach Krematorium.
David Boder: Ja.
David Boder: Also, Muselmann war eine abgef...[?] Person—und was haben die SS, sagen Sie, mit dem Muselmann getan?
Rita Benmayor: Gleich nach Krematorium.
David Boder: Und so, nun, eh, und so, wie lange waren Sie in Retzow?
Rita Benmayor: Drei Monat.
David Boder: Und denn, von dort sind Sie, wohin?
Rita Benmayor: Und dann wieder transportiert nach, eh, Malchow. Eine Tag und die zwei Tage—wir habt die Russe gekommen. Wir habt, eh,...
David Boder: Sind Sie freigekommen?
Rita Benmayor: Frei gek-...
David Boder: Nun, also, die Russen, eh, das war in Malchow?
Rita Benmayor: . . . Malchow.
David Boder: Na sagen sie mal, wenn die Russen Sie freigemacht haben, was hat denn passiert?
Rita Benmayor: Wir habt eine...
David Boder: Wo sind die SS gegangen, wenn die Russen gekommen sind?
Rita Benmayor: Die Früh, wir habt aufstehen, und wir habt ge- mit der SS geblieben...Und dann wir sind nach alle fünf nacheinander hinein, zu fünft, wir geblieben ganze Stunde dort, zu fünft und dann die SS weg...Wir habt geblieben ohne Russe, ohne Deutsch...
David Boder: Und...
Rita Benmayor: . . . wir habt ganz alleine geblieben, die Leute...
David Boder: Und was haben Sie getan, wer da....?
Rita Benmayor: . . . die Häftlinge.Wir habt laufen bei die Straße, so, Häftling alleine, und eh ganze Tag wir habt geblieben ohne Poste...
David Boder: Ohne Posten.
Rita Benmayor: Ohne Deutsche, ohne Posten.
David Boder: Sie sind, in der Straße...
Rita Benmayor: Nach wie...
David Boder: . . . oder sind Sie reingegangen zu den Deutschen, was haben die Deutschen gemacht?
Rita Benmayor: Gar nichts, die Deutsche immer weg.
David Boder: Die—die, die Privatleute, auch?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: No, sin...
Rita Benmayor: Die Privatleute auch, die hat ge...eine Koffer, eh, genommen und...
David Boder: Nun?
Rita Benmayor: Alle weg.
David Boder: Weg, weg.
Rita Benmayor: Wir hat nicht gesehen, wir hat bloß...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: So weg.
David Boder: Sind die Häuser offen geblieben, haben Sie mal reingeschaut?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: In die Häuser?
David Boder: Sind Sie reingegangen?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie was genommen, zum Essen, gefunden zum Essen?
Rita Benmayor: Ja, wir habt zu Hause ge-, gegangen, wir habt genommen zu Essen, wir habt genommen Kleider...
David Boder: Kleider?
Rita Benmayor: Und schnell wir weg.
David Boder: Und...
Rita Benmayor: Wir habt geblieben zwei Tage ohne Russe, ohne Deutsche...
David Boder: Hm...
Rita Benmayor: Und nach drei Tage wir habt gesehen Tanke...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: . . . wir habt gesehen...
Rita Benmayor: . . . die Russ gekommen. Und schnell, eh...
David Boder: Ja. Und?
Rita Benmayor: . . . ein Offizier gekommen, da wer ist Häftlinge, wer war in Lager, wir war schnell mit, eh, Offizier, und dann wir nach andere Lager mit Russe...
David Boder: . . . mit die Russen gegangen?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Zurück gegangen nach dem anderen...
David Boder: Zurück gegangen nach dem Lager mit Russen. Hat man Ihnen zu Essen gegeben?
Rita Benmayor: Und die Russen wir habt viel zu Essen gegebt, wir habe gut gemacht uns, wir habt Seife gegebt zu Waschen...
David Boder: Aha...
Rita Benmayor: Die war gut.
David Boder: Aha. Ja. Und dann sind Sie zurück gegangen, wohin?
Rita Benmayor: Dann wir habt zurück gegangen nach amerikanisch...
David Boder: Wo?
Rita Benmayor: Na, hat, viel laufen, eine, eine, drei Wochen laufen zu Fuß, wir hat gewollt in amerikanisch...
David Boder: Oh, Sie sind weggelaufen von die Russen?
Rita Benmayor: Ja, wir hat weglaufen von die Russen, wir hat gewollt mit amerikanisch gehen.
David Boder: Ja, und so, wo sind Sie...?
Rita Benmayor: Wir hat drei Wochen laufen sollt, wir hat, wir hat nicht gewusst...
David Boder: Wieviel Menschen sind Sie gelaufen?
Rita Benmayor: Wir wart 25 Menschen.
David Boder: Männer und Frauen?
Rita Benmayor: Männer und Frauen.
David Boder: Und wo sind Sie gegangen, durch Deutschland?
Rita Benmayor: Zurück in Deutschland nach amerikanisch...
David Boder: Nach der amerikanischen Seite?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Und wie lange hat das gedauert, dass Sie sind nach der amerikanischen Seite gekommen?
Rita Benmayor: Drei Wochen.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter, drei Wochen?
David Boder: Hat Sie keiner abgestellt, hat Sie keiner gesagt, wo geht Ihr?
Rita Benmayor: Nein, wir hat ein Adresse gehabt, wo die amerikanisch ist...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Und wir hat laufen so...
David Boder: Wo war das?
Rita Benmayor: Das war in Deutschland.
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Wo, war es die Seite war die Russen?
Rita Benmayor: Der hat eine Adresse genommen von eine amerik- von eine Offizier Russe, wir sagt wieviel Seite amerikanisch, wann woll gehen, kann laufen drei Wochen...
David Boder: [Laughs]...kann laufen drei Wochen...
Rita Benmayor: Wir hat laufen drei Wochen, wir hat gekommen bis amerikanisch...
David Boder: Und was haben Sie gegessen auf dem Weg?
Rita Benmayor: Wir hat gekommen zu Hause von die Deutschen, wir hat gestohlen zu Essen.
David Boder: Haben die Deutschen nicht selbst Ihnen zu Essen gegeben?
Rita Benmayor: Ja, es wie—Nein.
David Boder: Haben Sie es nicht wollen nehmen?
Rita Benmayor: Nicht gewollen, wir hat gestohlen.
David Boder: Gestohlen zu Essen?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Was haben Sie gestohlen?
Rita Benmayor: Brot, Butter, Zucker, eh, hat gestohlen...
David Boder: Von wo haben Sie das gestohlen?
Rita Benmayor: Und seh-, und zu Hause von die Deutschen.
David Boder: Wo die—wo die Deutschen weg waren, wo die nicht zu Hause waren?
Rita Benmayor: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie nicht getroffen Amerikaner, haben Sie nicht getroffen...
Rita Benmayor: Und dann nach drei Wochen, wir hat ge—wir hat gekommen Seite wo die Amerikanisch, und schnell die amerikanisch Kreuz, wir habt gegeben zu Essen, wir habt gegeben zu viel...
David Boder: Ja, aber die drei Wochen, das Sie gelaufen sind, waren Sie an der russischen Seite?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Und die Russen haben Sie lassen gehen?
David Boder: Aha. Und dann sind Sie durchgekommen zu die russische Seite und sind rüber gekommen zu die Amerikaner und dort hat das Rote Kreuz...
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Und die haben Sie ausgeholfen?
David Boder: Nun, warum und wieso sind Sie nach Paris gekommen?
Rita Benmayor: Ich hab nich, ich hab nicht gewollt nach Griechenland gehen, warum, ich hab nicht Familie...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Und ich mach ganz alleine in...
David Boder: Ja—nun?
Rita Benmayor: In Griechenland...
David Boder: Ja.—und so?
Rita Benmayor: Ich gehn in Griechenland, ich sehn meine Hause ohne meine Mutter, ohne Vater, ich kann nicht das sehen...Ich hab schnell, eh, er hat, ich hab gehabt zwei Freunde, Französe...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Er hat mir gesagt wollst du nach Paris gekommen? Ich hab gesagt: ja. Ich hab gekommen Paris.
David Boder: Wer waren die zwei Freunde?
Rita Benmayor: Zwei Französe.
David Boder: Mensch, eh, Männer oder Frauen?
Rita Benmayor: Frauen.
David Boder: Französische Frauen?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Und die waren mit Ihnen gelaufen?
Rita Benmayor: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Aha, und so sind Sie nach Paris gekommen, haben die Franzosen Sie rein gelassen?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Eh, sprechen Sie -, die Franzosen haben Sie reingelassen?
David Boder: Und wenn, sind Sie auf ein Zug gekommen, das Sie fahren konnten schon?
Rita Benmayor: Von Zug gekommen, ja.
David Boder: Wer, von wo haben, von der amerikanischen Seite?
Rita Benmayor: . . . von die amerikanische Seite.
David Boder: Dann sind Sie reingestiegen in einen Zug, um wegzufahren—Wieviel Menschen zusammen?
Rita Benmayor: Es war 150 Mensch.
David Boder: Ein spezieller Zug?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Mit Flüchtlinge?
Rita Benmayor: Mit Flüchtlinge.
David Boder: Und man hat Ihnen zu Essen gegeben und so?
Rita Benmayor: Ja, die amerikanisch viel zu Essen gegeben.
David Boder: Und dann sind Sie gekommen nach Paris?
Rita Benmayor: Nach Paris.
David Boder: Und wen haben Sie hier aufgesucht, wen haben Sie getroffen?
Rita Benmayor: Ich hab niemand getroffen, ich hab zwei Griechen, zwei Freunde Griechen, wir hab eine groß, mmh, Griechenkreuz gekommen...
David Boder: . . . ein rotes Kreuz?
Rita Benmayor: . . . Rotes Kreuz gekommen...
David Boder: Von Griechenland?
Rita Benmayor: Von Griechenland.
David Boder: Ja, und?
Rita Benmayor: Und er hat mir gegebt ein Kleid, ein Mantel und zu Essen...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Und dann die jüdische Organisation, er hat mir gegebt eine Hause zu wohn.
David Boder: Ja, eine—ja, und Sie wohnen hier jetzt?
Rita Benmayor: Und ich wohnt hier.
David Boder: Nun, und, eh, was tun Sie jetzt—was tun Sie jetzt hier [Ina ?]—was, wohin wollen Sie gehen, was wollen Sie tun?
Rita Benmayor: Ich geh nach Amerika.
David Boder: Oh, Sie gehn nach Amerika?
Rita Benmayor: Ich hab eine Onkel ge-...
David Boder: Wer hat Ihnen die Verwandte gefunden oder haben Sie gesucht?
Rita Benmayor: Ich hab gefunden eine Soldat...
David Boder: Eine...
Rita Benmayor: . . . eine griechisch Soldat, amerikanisch...
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Ja. Ich hab gesagt, vielleicht er kann meine Onkle—ich hab gegebt meine Adree, eh, die Adress ich hab nicht gewusst—ich hab gegebt die Name von mein Onkle, er hat gefunden.
David Boder: Der Soldat...
Rita Benmayor: Nur mit Name...die Soldat.
David Boder: Nun, wer ist Ihr Onkel?
Rita Benmayor: Und der Soldat hat schnell geschickt an meine Onkle und meine Onkle hat mi geschickt ein Brief.
David Boder: Ein, eh, einen Brief?
Rita Benmayor: Ein Brief.
David Boder: Hat man geschickt ein Affidavit?
Rita Benmayor: Ein Affidavit, er hat mir alle Papiere geschickt.
David Boder: So, warum gehen Sie nicht nach Amerika?
Rita Benmayor: Weil um die Quota für Griechen ist zu, ich kann nicht fahren.
David Boder: Und so, jetzt warten Sie hier, was tun Sie hier?
Rita Benmayor: Jetzt ich wart, bis wann die Quota is offen.
David Boder: Ja.
Rita Benmayor: Ich geh nach Amerika zu mein Onkel.
David Boder: Aha—und sind Sie hier ganz allein?
Rita Benmayor: Ganz allein.
David Boder: Und Ihr Bruder ist wo?
Rita Benmayor: Mein Bruder ist in Palästina.
David Boder: Palästina? Nun und nun jetzt sagen Sie mal, sie leben im selben Zimmer mit Frau, eh, Bottom...
Rita Benmayor: Bottom...
David Boder: Ja, und warum waren Sie in solch einer Eile heute morgen, zu arbeiten, was haben Sie gearbeitet?
Rita Benmayor: Ich geh in Arbeit—jede, eh,...Vakanz...
David Boder: Mmh.
Rita Benmayor: Alle...
David Boder: Aha.
Rita Benmayor: Alle Deko [?] ich kann nicht arbeit. Nach Moan, nach die Monat Septembre, wir gehn nach Arbeit.
David Boder: Was können Sie arbeiten?
Rita Benmayor: Ich kann etwas nähen?
David Boder: Sie können nähen, Sie wollen nicht Schuhe machen wieder?
Rita Benmayor: Nein.
David Boder: Warum nicht?
Rita Benmayor: Das war vom Lager.
David Boder: Und sie wollen nicht mehr?
Rita Benmayor: Nein.
David Boder: Aber Sie verstehen es noch?
Rita Benmayor: Ich kann.
David Boder: Ja.
David Boder: Und, eh, lernen Sie hier ein neues Fach oder Sie können nähen?
Rita Benmayor: Na, ich kann nähen.
David Boder: Ja, eh—wieviel sind Sie zur Schule gegangen in Griech-, in Saloniki—sind Sie zur Schule gegangen?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Wieviel Jahre sind Sie zur Schule gegangen?
Rita Benmayor: Mit 16 Jahre ich war in griechische Schule...
David Boder: Ja, eh—sagen Sie mal, eh, man sagt, dass da waren in Auschwitz Lieder, die die Mädchen gesungen haben—erinnern Sie sich, welche, welche Gedichte, die man da gemacht hat in Auschwitz?
Rita Benmayor: Nein.
David Boder: Keine Lieder auch nicht? Sie kennen keine Lager, Lagerlieder...-wa?
David Boder: Sie kennen keine Lagerlieder. Und, eh, wo ist Ihr Onkel in Amerika?
Rita Benmayor: In Hartford.
David Boder: In Hartfort, Connecticut? Was tut er dort [plenty] ?, was für Beschäftigung, was macht er dort?
Rita Benmayor: Die ein, ich habe zwei Onkel, die eine arbeit in die Fabrik, ich weiß nicht, was...
David Boder: Ja. Ja, und der andere?
Rita Benmayor: Der andere, ich weiß nicht, ich kann mich nicht...
David Boder: Sie wissen nicht, was der arbeitet? Nun, eh...aber Sie denken, Sie werden, eh, in, eh, in Jahr oder so ein Affidavit bekommen?
Rita Benmayor: Ja.
David Boder: Ja, und so lange werden Sie hier in Paris bleiben?
Rita Benmayor: Schon ein Jahr ich bin in Paris.
David Boder: Und Sie werden warten, bis das...
Rita Benmayor: Ich warte, wann die Quota von die Griechen ist auf...
David Boder: Was hat man Ihnen gesagt, wenn kann es offen sein?
Rita Benmayor: Ich, eh, die, die amerikanisch Konsulat, der weiß auch nicht...
David Boder: Der weiß es auch nicht—nun, es wird schon wahrscheinlich irgendetwas getan werden. Sehen Sie, dass Sie sich was hier auslernen können. Wenn nicht—im Ort irgendwas—ein schönes Fach auslernen?
Rita Benmayor: Ich wolln gern lernen.
David Boder: Ja, sie wollen—nun?
Rita Benmayor: Jeder—alle, hm...
David Boder: Alle sind in Vakanzen?
Rita Benmayor: Muss im Monat Septembre...
David Boder: Im Monat September werden Sie anfangen. Nun, ich danke Ihnen sehr, Fräulein Benmayor.
David Boder: [In Spanish] ¿Usted habla español?
Rita Benmayor: Sí.
David Boder: Y, eh...¿qué otros...eh qué otros idiomas habla?
Rita Benmayor: En Italiano...
David Boder: ¿De dónde aprendió el italiano?
Rita Benmayor: De la scuola.
David Boder: De la escuela...Y...eh...¿ya habla usted francés ahora?
Rita Benmayor: Sí.
David Boder: ¿Puede leer francés?
Rita Benmayor: Poco.
David Boder: Bueno, sería bueno que al final [ininteligible] este libro entonces.
Rita Benmayor: Sí.
David Boder: Bueno. Muchisimas gracias señorita.
Rita Benmayor: [In English] Yes.
David Boder: This concludes...this concludes the spool of the Illinois Institute of Technology, Spool 27, taken from Rita Benmayor, age twenty, tattoo 38758, and the triangle. Eh, she is a husky looking young woman, and eh, has her affidavit from America, but the quota is not yet open. The spool is, eh, of, eh, about twenty-six minutes length.